un contexte particulier pour l'ouverture
du salon des maires d'île de france 2010
9 difficultés quotidiennes des communes
et crise sociale des gilet jaune
le président de la république doit faire
des annonces suite au grand débat
national et les maires franciliens ont
des attentes
il ya manifestement des réformes à faire
on peut pas rester avec un mille feuille
territorial tout à fait que goûter aux
citoyens et dont les citoyens ne veulent
plus par qui ne se reconnaissent plus on
nous annonce vraiment une anticipation
de la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation beaucoup plus tôt que ce
qui était prévu puisque normalement
c'était pour la fin du mandat
sauf qu'on ne sait pas trop comment
financièrement ceux ci va être compensé
au niveau des villes mais je crois que
même en faut changer de logiciel pour le
pilotage de la france quel que soit les
mandats c'est vrai du mandat numéro si
demain on veut des gens encore plus
compétents avec stéphane bonnet maire d
evry courcouronnes la nouvelle la
commune nouvelle et président de
l'association des maires d'île de france
alors dans quel état d'esprit sont les
maires franciliens d'abord ils sont
toujours constructif et combatif ne sont
pas abattus
ils n'ont pas encore abandonné le navire
tout cas pour une grande majorité
d'entre eux non on est au moment d'abord
du bilan delà de ce mandat puisque c'est
le dernier salon avant la fin du mandat
on est aussi au bilan du long débat et
de l' affaire dite des gilet jaune avec
des cahiers de doléances que montré une
profonde défiance du peuple à l'endroit
dans les gares notamment du pouvoir
central
mais une forte demande en même temps de
renforcement du pouvoir local et donc du
coup après avoir été vilipendé et
traiter de clientéliste on voit que les
maires reviennent au coeur du débat et
redevienne nécessité dès lors qu'il
s'agit de retisser le lien social avec
les habitants donc on est dans cet état
d'esprit constructif et puis pour la
construction et la réinvention du modèle
communal de demain la décentralisation
elle a commencé dans les années 80
un premier acte ensuite un second tact
dans au début des années 2000 ça
ces moments de la terreur oui oui je
crois que c'est le moment de l'acte iii
se pose toujours la question évidemment
du millefeuille institutionnel se pose
toujours la question même si on enlevait
la clause de compétence générale aux
départements et aux régions du fait que
beaucoup de collectivités font la même
chose et dépensent de l'argent
inutilement on sait plus qui fait quoi
et qui fait voilà et puis de toute façon
se pose quand même la question des
relations de confiance et démocratique
avec les habitants et ça c'est les
maires qu'ils ont faim le seul élu
apprécié des français ça reste le maire
voilà c'est le seul qui est encore qui
est encore reconnue
si on ne renforce pas celui là si on ne
renforce pas la collectivité locale
alors on ne réformera jamais ce pays
présente aussi à l'ouverture de ce salon
la ministre de la cohésion des
territoires jacqueline gourault et la
présidente de la région ile de france
valérie pécresse chacune ont défendu
leur modèle de réforme de la
décentralisation une fois que ces
décentralisée il faut que les
collectivités territoriales au fonds
prennent leurs responsabilités c'est le
mot du président de la république
jusqu'au bout des compétences parce que
souvent on est encore dans un système où
l'état a un goût des compétences les
collectivités à notre bout alors il faut
certainement clarifier cela
moi je crois qu'il faut que le président
de la république comprenne que les
territoires et les élus et bien sont au
plus près des préoccupations des
français et qu'il faut décentraliser on
en a assez de la technostructure qui
doublonnent qui complexifie qui empêche
est interdit d échanges et des
rencontres avec leurs partenaires privés
et publics les maires partagent aussi
leurs expériences ce salon le dernier de
leur mandat avant les élections
municipales de 2020